你自己就可以是一样公司
这条视频 江湿的道会你可以把它
作为一人公司尤其是我
这种一人公司的总缸
我是真的一个人一样公司
就没开用公司就一个人
我上个一边刚教的个人所得碎
应该批很多小威起也教的需要多
所以这个我自己不要
是典型的一人公司 我是怎么做的
我一条一条给大家拆一
我自己的赚钱方法的话
其实在家的先法的第35叶
我其实给大家讲过了
对吧 我可以快乐给大家过一个
比如说我有个小允愿还其实就是我的这个
短期明正号
目前的话呢 三个
每天差不多
几百块钱
然后呢 我有个小允数店
有时候我的出窗
我有个夹这事就是我的转篮现在差不多八千人的吧
我有个电脑型的部分就是我的社群
差不多九千多人大概是这样
然后有个小型资金公司 我以前做资金现在也不做了
这个没有了 没有了
偶尔可以出去
在现在已经不受调了 然后另外一个是投资
就大概怎么一个收入
怎么做到的 我一步一步给大家分享
到底该怎么做
你看 老规约 想到哪儿说哪儿
但是这条视频很有用 我希望大家
跟着我一块做 别着急 怎么闷来
你看我现在拍视频都是这样的 就是不去考虑怎么进行
想到什么 说什么 我就靠一个东西
就是有用 就是有用 然后我直接说了
真程有用 做好事 好了 我们先说第一个
第一个是什么呢 似不啊 似不 第一个是什么呢
我在价值先法的32也提到了说
如果你对这个实际的理解是对的 听得很少 如果你对这个实际的理解是对的
那么你的口袋里应该有了你想了东西
否则就应该停下来
认真回想一下过去的生活
是不是哪里出了问题
要不要严着之前的轨迹继续生活下去
我们很能有一个缺点
比如说我赚不到钱 或者生活又在酒喝了
我就会想我怎么才能做更好的 它们认为是最近努力不够
那我觉得多看点吧 我在加班吧
其实你会发现更多的可能是你的那条路
有问题 这我明确本来说我每天的有效工作时间就俩有事
冲死的啥样是
我刚才说了 我的交得税
应该比很多小微弃也还多
所以
刚才我说的 如果你的口袋里没有你想和东西 一定是哪儿出了问题
所以要停下来
你是不是那一个书气啊
停下来
反思一下 我现在做的对不对的 没有更好的方法呢
你拿我来说我每个离拜
每个离拜
都会有一个反思的时间
比如说我每周二十时候我都会做个直播
你们有些人就可以看我的
我抓着直播 我卖货 多做广告
不是为了
包括也没有任何活动 就是给大家讲干握
其实这个直播对我来说的一个作用是什么
对我来说就是反思
因为我给大家讲的都是我在视潮的东西
我在讲给大家的时候其实我在反思复盘
所以我每周至少有一个反思复盘的时间
然后我们每过一段时间就会有些压位
你看我们这个月底就有一次先压会 会一把每次压会遇的过程中
其实又是我一个大兴的
真正有那么几天是
深度反思的复盘的一个过程
所以每次压会遇对我来说都是一个深度复盘的过程
所以第一个 你有没有用复盘
反思总结一下
第二个
你一定要记住学习的目的不是为了获得更多的知识
是能够
创作成品
我在书里很早的时候我曾经写过这么一段点人说
其实就是函书
你的每一个计较 你的每用一个东西都是函书
这里帮我说了
所有的知识都应该是可运行的
也就是可以被用出来的
就知识就一定要被用出来的
因为我以前是程选吗 所以我写的是函书
其实现在有压了这个函书就要死给我
叫镜能对不对
什么是函书呢
各位主要后白这段是非常非常非常非常用的了
什么是函书呢 你可以把它的一切为一个镜能
或者是一个能力
你书什么
经过一个处理输出
这就是一个函书 比如说回做法
给我书入什么输入就是一些新鲜的菜
然后我的处理函书切菜 多菜要做菜
出来就是菜
这个菜就是我的输出的
有多安于买单 这就是产品
对吧 所以把这个函书也好啊 这个是给我也好
你可以把它的一切为镜能
可能会更好的一切了
但是我还这么函书这个菜
各位 非常眼睛
或者你哪一章只跟着我来处理
你有哪些镜能
对出来
你以为哪些镜能 我说得慢一点
你以为哪些镜能
每一个镜能过一遍
这个镜能需要什么输入
对吧 我做菜 我需要很多菜 对吧
我做直播 播入 我需要有很多
这是输入很多输 比如说
它的处理过程是什么样子的
对吧 比如说我看一边说
我把它担心口罢
我要理解这个输的内容
然后在我的输入用出来
然后重新反思总结
然后我会说
这个输入的知识可以用在什么场景下的
然后的话我说怎么用的
为什么怎么用第一步第二步第三步
比此刻 我是这样的
这是处理过程
所以后场上输出
可能就是一个口罢的内容
或者是键条我才没的内容
对吧 人员员员员员员
为你这个口罢 知识会用
点赞 评论 收藏 关注
对吧 对吧 对说输出
好了 你的镜能有多少
它的输入什么 它的处理过程是什么
它的输出是什么
谁员员员员员员的输出买蛋
你的这个寒书有或者这个技能
多长时间没升级了
可是
它的列下你有哪些技能
输入输出
谁为这个输出买蛋
多长时间没升级了
把它列出来一个表来列完了以后
它就是你当下现状的原因
因为你生活中的每一次
应用都是这种技能的一个应用
或者这个寒书的钓用
然后你当下的现状就是那些技能的
钓用的结果
那么我说一个炸心的事
我们大部分人
可能一生
重要的就那么两个技能
而且是从安装上这个技能之后
就再也没有升级过
然后它有希望自己能赚到钱
可不可以 就是我讲的第二个
你有哪些技能
叫你个方法
如果你有AI的话我建议把这个
分享给AI
然后让AI
把能可知行的部分
自动知行
能理解吧
这个东西就到此级了
只是破两个部分这件事
第三个部分
你的收入了准什么
你的收入等着寒书的质量
寒书就进来吧
寒书的质量成为钓用的屏色
第一次量的寒书
高频钓用
应该是个大功在
第一次量的寒书
第一屏钓用
那个寒书那个经常是垃圾
认了他
高质量的寒书
电影器钓用
你再浪费
高质量的寒书
高频钓用
那个是寒书
所以拿我来说
我的很多寒书的质量成高的
对吧
比如说投资
我的寒书的质量是高的
比如说
你们大家所处置的
我把一个支持处理成
自媒体
这个我的寒书质量和寒书的
还是不一样的
而且我每天都交了他
对吧
这个就是
港版
我用的自媒体的港版
包括产品的技能
所以个为你把这个公司算一下
你就知道
你的哪些寒书应该升级的
哪些应该增加寒色钓用的
哪些应该宣除了
第四个部分
你一定要让你的
寒书让你的技能能够自动运行
就是
他应该是一个系统
什么系统呢
就是你不在场的时候
他仍然能够
创造价值
我们最绝的是这个东西
对吧
比如说我
我投资
我不在场的时候
特别让人能够传到价值
再举过了一则
比如说拍个人品
其实我是完全可以做的
我不在场
自动就可以做的
但是我不需要
因为我把每一次
扣播都是当作
一次书书书盘的
自我总结的一个过程
所以你看我和别人不养
我拍视频
不是想的时候有多少量
其实我就是把他
作为一个我给别人分享
真正有个东西
同时自我反思
自我总结自我改进的一个过程
所以我不让他交给
只可以让他交给来的
好了
然后你会发现
有那些寒书
没用了
你要把它删掉
就好像那个房间的一个东西
你觉得他有用
搬去了
觉得有用搬去了
过来你会发现
他没用
他其实对你这个环境
是污染
所以你应该把
一些没用的东西
认识
然后有些真正的东西
你要反复
掉过他不断的去升级
你拿我来说
我其实是有一个AI的
我会不断的监冲
哪些寒书的一些
丢丢丢次数最多的
哪些寒书不断的
然后我会不断的幽黄
我的系统
所以你会发现
我很多时候我的系统
是动运转的
然后我每天只需要工作了
这两个小时
还是因为我资源的
其实还可以再有
但是
那两个小时工作是我的
来系统了
我不想把它再有化了
我就全都还没意思
就我还是需要
自我去去体会他
我就能去消费了
你看
这就是我作为一下
公司的
整个的一个过程
似不过我在总结里
首先第一个
你的口袋里应该就有你想要的
如果你口袋里没用你想要的
你一定是拿出来的问题
一定要反思总结一下
所以你必须给自己设议过
时间避
周期性的
每过一段时候反思总结一下
没有东西的时候
没有拿到东西的时候
一定不是因为你不过努力
肯定是在塞造出问题了
你好好想想
这是第一个问题
一定要有反思不断的时间
第二个部分
学习的目的是
能够床造
能够生产东西
而不是为了需要很多知识
有很多知识无法运行的
比如说你搜射墙墙的东西
看了视频点赞
看见这个东西点赞
这个把它打收场
那个都是不能运行的东西
上一个客气的利益
那都是不能运行的
真正进行的东西
一定能够才能夹势
所以我用寒书这个词
对
好好想一想
你都有哪些亲人
书什么
说的过程什么
谁问你的书说买单
多长时间没什么
一定要听说
烈了完了以后你就知道
为什么你是现在的你了
这个技能从哪来
一个是总结自己过去成功的经验
一个是细去别人成的经验
AI能防疫
跟来讲
你过去做一些什么事
怎么做的
怎么成功呢
让他把你总结
撑进来的扶用
学习的东西
把你交给
让他去动用
好的
别散个部分
你的收入等于
寒书的治疗
成为月
掉为我的偏层
对
所以应该要把你现在做的事情
都灭灭灭
灭来看看哪个问题
该提升屁肢的提升屁肢
该降低屁肢
降低屁肢
该闪到的分调
该升于寒书的生产
几能够
该升屁
我之前说了
我们很久就最大的问题是什么
主要
是说年前
掌握的一个技能
到现在未知都没有升屁股
这四个部分
定期
删出一些没用的技能
然后升降的那个
有用的基督发挥到几层
就像忙碌说的就
只喝的方法很简单
就是你发现什么是有用的
不断掉我的
什么是没用的
以后就不要再用了